you must find a way to serve
if you're going to try something
innovative then then you're in
unexplored territories so that
odds that something will go wrong are
pretty high i bought a book in 1949
by a fellow named ben graham called the
intelligent investor i don't remember
what i paid
but aside from what i paid for my two
marriage licenses that was the best
investment i ever made
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven lessons from
elon musk warren buffett and
other billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one find a way to
serve with oprah winfrey you must find
a way to serve
martin luther king said that
not everybody can be famous but
everybody can be great because greatness
is determined
by service now we live in a world where
everybody wants to be famous
and where we admire people for just
being famous we think being known
brings us value the truth is all of that
will fade in time in three years you
won't be able to name the housewives
of banana
[Music]
the real truth is that
service and significance
service and the significance that you
bring to your service
is that which is lasting so to be able
to
whatever your occupation or job or
talent or gift is
our honorees today getting doctor
degrees
to apparently opposite fields
hiv and aids and the spoken word
but what they have in common is service
using the spoken word in service to
community and the world
using your knowledge and information
about hiv and aids and medicine
in service to the world and if you look
at all the most
successful people in the world whether
they know it or not
they have that paradigm of service
everybody's talking about mark
zuckerberg and ipo
[Music]
service jay-z rapid
service through the word to people
through song for many years i was really
just happy to be on tv and people would
stop and say oh you're on tv yeah i'm on
tv
i like being on tv it's a nice job
and it was about the time that i
received my
honorary doctorate from spelman around
1993 so i don't know if that had
something to do with it i thought of
myself as dr winfrey
that i went back and i took a long look
at what it was i was doing on
on tv and made a decision
that i was no longer going to just be on
tv
but i was going to use tv
as a platform as a force for good
and not be used by tv and i will tell
you
my decision to make that
significant change in the way i operated
on television using television as a
service
changed my career exponentially
service through medicine service through
art using whatever it is
you produce your product
as a way of giving back to the world
when you shift the paradigm of whatever
it is you choose to do
to service and you bring significance to
that
success will i promise you
follow you service and significance
equals success lesson number two accept
failures with elon musk
if you're going to try something
innovative then then you're in
unexplored territories so that
odds that something will go wrong are
pretty high uh
if you know it's only if you try to do
something that is already well
understood that
um there's a little little chance of
failure
but then it will not be uh interesting
or innovative um
so you know for sure uncharted territory
will result in
um failures uh necessarily
otherwise you know trying hard enough
lesson number three think long
term with jeff bezos what do you say to
employees
when you have obviously have some
traders in the stock who are not happy
and suddenly the stock is down 25
after a quarter well i so
for well since 1997 at
almost every all hands meeting we have
two all hands meetings a year
at almost every all hands meeting i
remind employees
that you know if the stock is up 10 this
month don't feel 10
smarter because when the stock is down
10 some month you're going to have to
feel 10 percent dumber and it's not
going to feel as good
and so it's you know ownership is
we give most of our compensation
is is done in terms of stock
compensation
and and part and parcel with ownership
is the mentality of long term
thinking you know you owners think
longer term than renters do
so i have a friend who rented his house
to some tenants and
instead of getting a christmas tree
stand at christmas they just nailed the
christmas tree into the hardwood floors
of the house no owner would ever do that
and um but sometimes that's a bad tenant
you know they're a good
good tenants but that's a bad tenant and
it's because you know this is the same
old thing about you know nobody ever
washed a rental car and um
you you take better care of the things
that you own and and
uh but but one of the responsibilities
of ownership
and definitely deep inside the amazon
culture
is to think about the fundamentals of
the business and not the daily
fluctuations in the stock price
it's no there's no information in it
also if you want to have more self
belief and more self-confidence i've
created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below for people
who didn't get the love they need no
matter where it is you grew up
you spend the rest of your life trying
to fill that thing i've always been
passionate
some people thought you know it's it's
more ocd than anything else
when you want to do something new you
you have to you have to apply
the the physics approach lesson number
four
have the right framework with warren
buffett i was wondering if you have any
stock tips for any of the students you
know who are all trying to
uh make make a little living i didn't
think they taught that at georgetown
they now they the best the best
investment i ever met well
i i bought a book in 1949 by a fellow
named ben graham called the intelligent
investor
i i don't remember what i paid but aside
from what i paid for my two marriage
licenses that was the best investment i
ever made
and uh it's very important
to have the right framework you need you
need
you need to have an approach to
investing that sound and
graham's approach is is simple uh
but some people uh adopt to it
and and which i did immediately and and
most people don't
but if you have the right philosophy you
will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years and
and frankly you're most likely to find
them uh
when in periods like five years ago when
we were having
the panic i mean that uh
stocks sell at silly prices from time to
time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
uh and it doesn't take
a high iq to figure out that they're
cheap
but it does take a temperament that's
willing to step
up and actually act i tell people if
they're going in the investment business
if you got 160 iq sell 30 points to
somebody else because you won't need it
i mean that
that it yeah i mean i figured out very
early you don't have to be that smart of
this business which is fortunate
but you do have to have the right
temperament and you have to be able to
ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts
and decide is this stock which is
selling it
x worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if
when you don't find them you don't do
anything so that's my
generalized stock tip no names lesson
number five
do the impossible with jesse itzler i
just realized that i'm an adrenaline
junkie
i love newness i love challenges i mean
that's what makes me feel most alive
and i discovered that early on when i
was trying to get a record deal
and just getting rejection and i didn't
i had no connections
my dad owned a plumbing supply house in
long island where i grew up
and we weren't connected to the music
world and i just loved the thrill of
trying to
do what everyone said i couldn't do
there's no way you could you know
whenever all my roommates in college
were writing
their resumes and sending it out to all
the companies they're like why aren't
you writing
your resume we're all like typing our
resume why are you working on it i'm
like
because i'm going to get a record deal
and when they said no you can't
it just fueled me more to want to go out
and get it
lesson number six have good core values
with john paul de georgia
what are your core values personally and
professionally
core values are i would say it's the
golden rule
do unto others as you would have others
do unto you
that's the basis for most religions but
they get sometimes carried away in
rights and rituals
but that's the core value do unto others
as you'd have others do unto you
and then it's the feeling of knowing
that success
unshared is definitely failure in other
words when you make it
it's not really just about yourself
making it hey if you make it you know
you made it
but along the way one of the great
lessons to learn
is it's not all about you it's about
your ability to be of service to this
planet while you're here
and by saying me me me me look what i
did this is me hey here's my building my
name's on it you know i did this you
didn't
by doing something like that it kind of
takes away
from how genuine you are and because
people don't like to just listen to
people talk about themselves how great
they
are they want to know incorporate it to
make them successful also or do
something a little different and i think
that's
very very important and lesson number
seven the last one before a very special
bonus clip
is do it better than everybody with mark
cuban
you're talking to you know alluding to
it earlier about entrepreneurs being
born or built you know and i think
they're
i knew i was wired to be excited about
business
how or why i don't know but you know and
there's certain guys they have the
genetics to jump out of the gym right
certain guys you know that you know when
they golf they have the muscle memory
and
and the discipline you know dirk um the
whiskey may not be the most talented guy
in the nba
but his discipline and his focus to do
what's necessary to be successful
he's willing to do and combine it with
being seven feet tall and being skilled
you know it makes him an amazing
basketball player
so it's understanding what your skill
set is
finding the right place to use those
skills and then
going for it you know will that make you
250 grand it depends if you pick the
right industry
but whatever industry you pick if you
outwork everybody
if you try to be a little smarter than
everybody if you try to be a better
sales person than everybody
if you try to be better prepared than
everybody you've got your best chance
because
if you don't do it and somebody else
does
you know i have the same work like
someone's trying to take it all away
from you you know working
actually working like someone's spending
24 hours working 24 hours to take it all
away from you
and that's kind of the way i look at it
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through that's what we do here
believe nation
we get motivated but then we do
something about it
and when you commit to other people you
increase your chances even further of
following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video and then what is your plan of
action around
for this week put it down in the
comments below because i want to
celebrate
you it's really important to
differentiate yourself
i say that more than anything you've got
to get to the point and you've got to
give the what's in it for them very
concisely and very quickly so
with with differentiating yourself i'll
use an example
i always say you've got to differentiate
you've got to tell the person
or the world why you're unique and why
you're different
very clearly and concisely then you have
to let them know why you're unique and
different in comparison to other options
they may have
and then you need to let them know why
that matters to them
so i'll use my own journey and just give
you the example
i also say it's really important to sell
the problem you're solving
not just the product
so i'll take my spanx so when i first
invented spanx if i were to plug
in this equation and how important it
was the first thing i said to the buyer
or anybody if i was in the media if i
got a chance to be on the news
i would say do you have you know you
know how women have things hanging in
their closet that we have no idea what
to wear under
and then they would nod and so i
immediately started with the problem
creating the problem that i'm now about
to solve then i would say
and then you know how our underground
options they're not that great you have
regular underwear that leaves a panty
line that you can see or these very
thick heavy duty girdles that are too
thick under your beautiful clothes or
your nice slacks
and leave lines on your legs okay then
i've just given them the options that
are dysfunctional
and then i tell them well i've just
invented this product and look what it
does
it meets in the middle of the options
that are out there and here's why it's
going to be important to you here's why
it's going to matter
you're going to be able to wear white
you're going to be able to wear cream
you're finally going to be able to wear
all the
fabrics in your closet that you don't
wear anymore and you're gonna
you're gonna look amazing you're gonna
have no lines so then i would give the
what's in it for them but that's just a
quick example and i would always
i like to start with the problem that
i'm solving have them just sort of
invest in it with you and then um
why the other options aren't so great
people need to know
from you you're the only one that can do
it why you're their best choice
don't don't assume that they're going to
just try to figure it out people are
busy people are
you know we got a lot on our mind tell
me even in an interview when i'm
interviewing people i want them to say
i'm your best candidate and here's why
and be very clear about it
if you want seven more lessons from how
billionaires think check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there people like invention
but the problem is they don't like
failure
and you cannot have invention without
failure